IT'S TIME TO
PLAYFUL BLOWN MARITAL AIDS.
FULL BLOWN MARITAL AIDS.
VALENTINE'S DAY IS THIS WEEKEND.
IT'S AWESOME IF YOU'RE IN A
HAPPY RELATIONSHIP, DEPRESSING
IF YOU'RE SINGLE, AND AWKWARD IF
YOU'VE BEEN DATING YOUR TINDER
HOOKUP FOR LESS THAN A MONTH.
SO I'M GONNA SHOW YOU SOME
UNUSUAL VALENTINE'S DAY GIFTS WE
FOUND ONLINE AND FOR 250 POINTS,
YOU HAVE TO GIVE THEM TAGLINES
TO SELL THEM.
HERE'S THE FIRST ONE -- TWINSIE.
IT'S LIKE A ONESIE, BUT TWICE AS
EMBARRASSING.
ALWAYS BE READY FOR A
THREE-LEGGED RACE.
YES, BARRY.
>> FOR THE COUPLE THAT LIKES TO
[BEEP] EACH OTHER PANTS.
>> Chris: POINTS.
JUDAH.
>> PERFECT FOR CUDDLING DURING A
HOME INVASION.
>> Chris: POINTS. POINTS.
>> I LIKE THE PICTURE THAT WOMAN
NEVER MET HIM AND JUST WOKE UP
IN IT.
>> YEAH, HER HANDS ARE LIKE,
HELP!
>> Chris: ALL RIGHT, NEXT ONE.
THE WiFi ENABLED KISS
MESSENGER ROBOT THAT LET'S
COUPLES SEND VIRTUAL SMOOCHS TO
EACH OTHER
♪
>> Chris: OKAY.
LET ME EXPLAIN THAT TO YOU.
THIS INTIMATE ROBOT ALLOWS YOU
TO TRANSMIT SENSATIONS.
YOU KISS WILL YOU THROUGH A
ROBOT BASICALLY.
SO, IT'S SORT OF LIKE A SHORT
CIRCUIT THREEWAY, IF THAT MAKES
ANY SENSE.
ANNIE.
>> BECAUSE SOMETIMES WHEN YOU'RE
IN A LONG DISTANCE RELATIONSHIP
YOU NEED A COLD PLASTIC THING
FOR YOUR OTHER LIPS.
>> Chris: YES, POINTS.
I MEAN, I GUESS.
>> THAT'S A GENDERED ONE.
>> Chris: I'LL TAKE YOUR WORD
FOR THAT. BARRY?
>> UH, YEAH. YOUR BOYFRIEND IS
GOING TO TRY TO [BEEP].
>> Chris: POINTS.
NEXT ONE.
TWODALOO, THE TOILET FOR
COUPLES.
JUDAH.
>> THE COUPLE THAT GETS FOOD
POISONING TOGETHER, STAYS
TOGETHER.
>> Chris: YES, POINTS.